okay let's try that again
ciao a tutti Godse para ver participial
Alameda score so that's as much it's a
an Italian that I can speak thank you
for joining me for this target this
afternoon with the looming weather that
is coming up I really appreciate that
you made the way here to my talk what am
I going to talk about today is Google
cloud spanner or horizontally global
distributed relational database and I
gonna talk a little bit in more detail
how everything works but before that I
want to put a couple of words to my
person in terms of like what my job at
Google as a developer advocate at Google
and we understand our job as being a
bi-directional interface so to say
between developers that build on our
products and the developers within
Google that built products for you so
please feel free to reach out to me on
Twitter or so get up if you have liked
constructive feedback if you have some
ideas what you want to do with Google
cloud platform or certain products and
we're happy to be there for for you to
respond to you now what am I going to
cover today in this talk is I want to
give a brief history about like how
spanner was built within Google and why
it was bolt
I gotta go a little bit more in detail
about it like what is the Edit feature
set in terms of cloud spanner like what
are we adding to the version that we
have internally and then I will spend a
fair amount on explaining the inner
workings of spanner and give a demo now
why did we build spanner let's go back
about 12 years and Google has been at
that point running on top of I sharted -
Cal so we had a database which was
shorted based on the custom ID our STS
was running through it and there are a
lot of millions of dollars basically
back on this chart at MySQL system now
since we were growing really fast we had
to basically recharge that database
multiple times and the last time we
charge the days up that that database it
took over two or two years to reach out
that database so clearly this was not a
solution that we could go forward in the
terms of like scalability that we needed
so what did we really need from a
database where lots of customers are
basically betting their their money on
so we had customers with budgets we had
our own systems that needed basically
transactional consistency as a back-end
so we needed a database with scales
horizontally which supports asset
transactions and most importantly that
can support no downtime updates of
security updates and schema updates and
things like that recurs every time we
basically had to shut down our back-end
it would be loss of money for us and
lots of our customers as well so this
was not acceptable
also because we were dealing with
people's money eventually consistency
was not acceptable to us either so fast
forward about 10 12 years that we were
running cloud spanner inside of Google
we made it now available for all of you
to basically use it on with your
applications but we added a couple of
things which we think are really
important for cloud solution to offer
that under the portfolio of Google cloud
platform so one of the very first thing
is Google cloud spanner comes as a fully
managed service it is the same back-end
the same engineering the same technology
that we use internally for our spanner
but you get it basically through a UI
fully managed very easy to set up and
then within seconds available for you
it's still the same performance and
global consistency that we have inside
also what is really important is we
wanted to meet people and developers
where they are in terms of familiarity
with interacting with relational
databases so spanner supports the
familiar SQL ANSI 2011 standard it has
the traditional relational semantics and
acid semantics also spanner supports an
automatically synchronous replication
for like original
and multi-regional setups and it is
battle-tested within google for more
than five years now for regional set ups
we provide actually four nines of rate
of availability which boils down to four
minutes and 38 seconds roughly of
unavailability that we accept for a
regional set up later this year
we will support a multi regional set up
that can span the globe where you get
five nines of availability for that set
up which basically boils down to about
twenty six seconds for months in
unavailability that we guarantee now
another thing which was really important
for us was when we were working with our
early access customers to help them
integrate loud spanner into their
applications so we were looking at it's
like okay like how can we make it as
easy as possible to adapt loud spanner
one I already mentioned was SQL that we
support SQL that we will support one SQL
standard across our product portfolio so
there has been in the past multiple SQL
dialects we now switch to SQL ANSI 2011
across our our portfolio so bigquery has
also spanner supports on the eleven at
2011 for all of our data that is stored
in in spanner it is encrypted at rest
and in-flight and we added things like
audit locking and integration of our I
am so in the Identity and Access
Management so that you can control
access to data within spanner with the
launch we provide also the client
libraries so in four languages and we
are working hard on more languages to
add to these so currently we have Java
go Python and nodejs as the languages
that you can use today out-of-the-box we
also have a REST API and the GOP ceased
app if you want to build your own client
libraries in a different language and we
provide a read-only JDBC driver to
integrate with things like BI tools wire
from partners and things like that so
how does spanner compared to like a
traditional database or non SQL scalable
database if you look at spanner in once
I would describe it as you get related
like the database with the semantics of
a relational database with the
scalability of a [ __ ] of a new SQL
database so what does that mean
spanner provides you things like a
strong steamer strong teat strong type
Sima provide to SQL which a lot of you
probably are familiar with it provides
you strong consistency and the way that
spanner works behind the scenes adds all
the things like high availability and
horizontal scalability all the data is
automatically replicated to read
replicas and also I will go into more
detail in terms of the architecture like
how we achieve the high availability and
the horizontal scalability now somebody
is like say like ok like some many of
these things I can get from a
traditional relational database as well
so yes but many scenarios if you look at
the scalability for instance you look at
a scenario where you for instance have
in my chart at my scale or shorted post
dress now if you want to get scalability
there there are certain things that you
can do for once you can for instance add
some Reid replicas to offload some
workload from your master and by that
scale scale more for your rights on your
master but you basically have to hope
that your cloud provider or your machine
producer gives you a bigger machine as
your system is growing as your business
is growing so you kind of run out of
headspace eventually at some point what
like in the terms of the amount of data
that you can manage with a traditional
relational database or the amount of
reads and writes that you can handle
with that system now also oftentimes if
you go into the charted world of my
scale or Postgres you lose a lot of the
qualities of the underlying database
system and a lot of the semantics you
have to put up into your business logic
which makes the whole system very
complex so now over spanner you
basically can put this logic back into
the database and you don't have to care
in your application layer about it now
comparing to non SQL database you
basically don't have these things where
you have
Vica ball consistency where you might
have to deal with eventual consistency
for like a Cassandra or MongoDB or
things like that so you basically have
given the highest standard of sterilized
ability of spanner external sterilized
ability and there's no like way around
that that's basically what you get and
they will always have now if we look at
the typical workloads where spanner is
used I want to emphasize on two areas
where spanner is really strong one is I
mentioned no downtime schema and
security updates behind the scenes
basically for spanner which makes
spanner a very high availability so if
you have a system which is
mission-critical where you cannot accept
any down times banner even if you have
not a lot of data spanner is your your
choice that's something where you should
look into another thing is in terms of
scalability for read writes and data
size so if you want to scale
horizontally for your reads and writes
in transactions
you know spanner is again a very good
solution for for this you won't get the
very low latency query times you might
get with some of the vertical scalable
solutions but in the end your if you
design your database well from the query
from a schema and query standpoint you
can basically with adding nodes scale
very well horizontally and you don't get
the hockey stick at the end if you get
out of capacity on your notes so things
where we see a lot of usage for these
kinds of workloads is for instance like
financial system inventory management
very neat kind of like a global
consistent database and things where you
need a lot of reads and writes for a
matter of fact if we look at the global
data plane Google cloud platform
everything in terms of the management of
resources and api's and virtual machines
inspect by spanner as a global data
plane another use case said we see and
that you can use span of wars since it's
scalable in terms of the size of data it
can handle is database consolidation so
in
that of running your daily ATL drops of
like extracting them data from like a
new SQL solution and then extracting
some account data from from your
relational database and then running
some analytics on that you can basically
think of putting all this data into one
database and without the hassle of
having ETLs everywhere so with that I
want to look into like how does spanner
actually achieve these things that I
just claimed I claimed horizontal
scalability I said I claimed that it can
grow and database size up to terabytes
and petabytes and a claim that it can
handle a lot of like read and write
loads so the way that spanner is doing
this is a separation of compute vs.
storage so if you look here this is an
example of regional set up so I have a
regional instance I create that regional
instance and one of my preferred regions
and when I start like and buy 3 nodes I
get actually behind the scenes 9 nodes
so all the 3 notes that I buy are
replicated three times in three zones
now in each of these zones I have
storage basically so the storage is
replicated as well now if we look at the
terminology in terms of like what are
the visible items for spano database in
the instance from a client side and what
are what is behind the scenes to enable
the horizontal scalability we start with
an instance that we just saw so you
basically set up your regional incident
that defines how many nodes you have how
many where this region in the instance
lifts or later in this year we have a
multi regional instance so you can
decide where your multiple regional
instance lives in each of these
instances you can create multiple
databases up to 100 databases and then
in each database you create tables as we
are familiar with from a MySQL database
for instance now these tables are behind
the scenes we split these tables by key
ranges and these splits are done based
on the primary key and by range now what
enables display
the splitting enables us to horizontal
scale so how do we do this basically the
computer sources that we have available
in our regional instance are responsible
for multiple spits so the splits are
basically parts of data in your database
now basically a split as part of a table
now we see that in all of these regions
we basically have a compute node or
computer source which is responsible for
split one here in this example and we
have app access group formed by these
three compute nodes that are responsible
for the split one now we use paksas tool
to select a leader in this group and now
once we have this leader we can make
sure that only one compute node is
responsible for in gating basically
writes write transaction on that data
piece by that we can make sure that we
have global consistency because there's
never two leaders for a data piece now
you could imagine like in a distributed
world this would incur a lot of
communication to make sure that we have
at most one responsible compute node for
a data piece the way that we remove some
of this communication overhead is with
an innovation that we specifically did
for for spanner and it is called true
time now what is true time imagine
you're sitting next to your neighbor and
you're trying to synchronize your
watches
now you go off and meet again in a
couple of hours you have been exposed to
different temperatures different ISO ISO
spheric surveys and things like that
your your clocks will drift away from
each other so it's really hard actually
to synchronize clocks even in a small
vicinity of a room now think of
synchronizing clocks globally across
data centers now true time actually
achieves that by a very smart technology
and semantic way what true time does is
actually we use GPS to synchronize our
data centers clock wise and we use
atomic clocks
these data centers to basically keep a
very accurate time now still we cannot
use just the single timestamp to make
sure that this timestamp is the exact
time send everywhere on the world we
have to quantify interval which
basically gives us the uncertainty of
this timestamp what does that mean a lot
of words
it basically means we get with true time
a lower bound and an upper bound of a
timestamp the lower bound of the times
then tells us that this time stem has
passed everywhere in the world the upper
bound of that interval gives us the time
stem which tells us this time stem
definitely hasn't passed anywhere in the
world
now with these two times then we can
make sure that there's only one leader
exactly one leader for data pace and by
that we get the sire of the external
Cyril eyes ability for our transactions
that we provide now in terms of like the
the interval how long is that roughly in
our paper we publish that it's in the
single-digit milliseconds interval in
terms of like the lower bound and the
upper bound now what happens if for
instance in my data center all atomic
locks fail and all GPS fails what
happens in this case is that we actually
go to a different data center to get
these through time and we will calculate
in the travel time of the data basically
from our data center the next data
center now with that the interval
basically widens and the data base flows
down but the data database doesn't stop
so that is really important the data
base even in the case that we lose
atomic clocks or we lose GPS in a data
center the database will continue
working and will continue working in a
cons very consistent and global
consistent way so let's demonstrate that
on on a query here in this example I
select from my event table all the
events that have the name next Malan so
in a consistent read scenario I
basically send a request from my client
and in this case it comes in through my
read replicas and the read replicas will
go to the leader for that data piece in
my pack says crew and will ask like hey
do I have the latest data basically
sends the timestamp of the data that the
replay read replica already has now the
leader will response yes you have the
latest data and the data will be served
from my read replica in the case said
the read replica doesn't have ticks
the most recent data the leader will
just respond no you don't have the data
just wait till that timestamp and once
you see that times them you can respond
the data the reason is that the data is
already in flight when this question is
basically asked so we don't need to send
the data back even if the read replica
doesn't have the latest data so I
basically just made out at that time
you basically wade through that time
stem our upper upper power and time send
them to time wait out the time that we
got from the leader and once we have
that times them and we have the data we
can we can basically respond now we also
support something called stale or
inconsistent reads time bounded sweets
when are the easier useful imagine you
have multi-regional set up and this is
globally distributed between yes Europe
and and Asia now time bonded queries
gives you the possibility to basically
read data that is a little bit older in
a way that you say okay I accept data
that is up to 15 seconds old now in that
case the reader replicas can check do I
have data that is at most 15 seconds old
and if that is the case it basically can
respond immediately without consulting
the leader of that data piece which
could go across the ocean in in some
cases to to check if that data is
actually the most recent one now what
happens in the retry transaction in a
retry transaction when I start that
transaction and I basically do within
the three Dwight transaction context I
do a query I'm directly routed to the
leader of that paksas group of that for
which
is responsible for that data piece now
the leader will acquire locks returned
the results I do some modification on
that and then I'm sending basically the
modifications to the leader and the
leader will send out the modification to
the group the package group once the
leader receives a majority of
acknowledgment from all the participants
in that group and considers this
transaction committed will basically
release the locks and return to the
client a success of that transaction if
we look at the data layout which spanner
supports I mentioned that it supports
traditional SQL ANSI SQL in the same way
as like other databases so we also have
the relational models that you're
familiar with with strongly typed
schemas relational schema so you see
here creating a single table and an
album table with an ID and some single
name and an album ID now if you look at
like database like MySQL you have things
like foreign key constraints or
referential integrity that you can get
that we don't support that in the
distributed system but we have something
which is basically a foreign key
constraint - - and that is called
interleaved tables
what are interleaved tables now
interleave tables give you co-located
data locality in the sense of here I
have my singers table and I have my
album table and I interleave that album
table into my singers table now all this
data is basically put in one split that
I talked about which is like a part of
that table with it will be put all in
one split per row so you have the the
Beatles over here and the example and
every album for the Beatles will be
living in the same split as the row the
where the Beatles lives in and that
gives you kind of like a bridge or in in
terms of like that joins can be answered
very quickly from one compute node that
is controlling and responsible for that
split
so if we do this for our data models
that we've just seen be basically just
ad and interleaved in and we have to
make sure that the interleave table
shares the primary keys of the the outer
table and then we can basically it'll
leave the table also what's really
important here is that we support no
downtime scheme update so you can add
columns you can change like size
attributes of columns so you can go from
a string xx to the string 50 things like
that all these scheme updates run in
actually in a transaction so there are a
couple of things you have to be aware of
when you might create from a traditional
MySQL database on Postgres or any of the
major bigger database vendors to cloud
spanner to keep the scalability now one
of the things is that like our heavily
used or that many times are used in the
traditional database are things like
Auto increment ID as a primary key now
this is actually poison for for spanner
in terms of the of the horizontal
scalability and I will get into it a
little bit more detail about that so
don't use any monitoring increasing or
decreasing primary keys don't use any
timestamps for s primary keys in your in
your schema also be careful in terms of
like how much you use interleaving I
mentioned all of this that lives
basically in the split of the parent
table which means like if you interleave
like huge tables into one row of your
parent table you also run out of
capacity in terms of resources for that
note that is handling that split so if
we look at like using for instance time
stamps for primary key what would what
you would end up with is a hot spotting
one of your compute nodes in managing
that data so imagine you loading your
data as beta database and you're putting
the time stamp as as the primary key
what what you end up with is that all
your new data that you load into the
database ends in the last split of your
table
ah split is handled by one one computer
source now to avoid this you can do
things like using you IDs version 4 or
you using like shouting shouting IDs so
what does that look like if you look and
everything is also on our documentation
you find more detailed explanation about
how you can optimize your schemas and
your workloads to not bottleneck on
hotspot on certain things now if you for
instance use a sharding ID what it will
look like is we now prefix our our
primary key with a shotting ID and by
that we na below out the workload across
multiple computer sources as you can see
here with this I want to go in a little
demo so we already switched perfect so
your first first top point if you want
to learn more about cloud spanner and if
you want to get your hands on spanner is
cloud comm a cloud at google.com slash
spanner where you find a multitude of
resources around documentation how to
use it but also things like case studies
as you can see down here we have case
study with twist led that moved and
migrated from charted MySQL to spanner
and does a lot of like analytics around
like what did we have to change in our
applications to do this migration I'm
also asked like quite a couple times
today already like the spanner defeat
the cap theorem spanner does not defeat
the cap theorem and you can read and
detail around a take of the inventor of
the capillary marry prove take on that
in terms of like in contrast to spanner
but basically what I can say is spanner
as a CP system but the infrastructure
that supports spanner within Google has
not failed us in the way that we did not
have a network petition so far with our
internal spanner system so the strong
infrastructure that we have
within Google basically gives us the
reliability and this like a very
unlikely scenario of a partitioning
where we would in that case result to a
consistent system and would become
unavailable now for regional set up we
basically give an SLA four of four 9s
and for me imagine regionals that are we
give an SLA of five nines of
availability for for this now if you
want to get started with spinner the
first thing that you do is create your
instance and that couldn't be easier
than doing spinner playground giving a
name it automatically gives you an
instance ID you choose one of the four
regions that we currently support which
is basically in Asia East and most east
of Taiwan and Japan and also Europe in
Belgium and us in Iowa so for this
example I will choose Europe you choose
the amount of notes that you want to
start with you click create and within
seconds you have an arrow all right
let's see if I have enough quota to have
at least one note awesome okay
so I didn't have enough total for ten
notes but I have at least enough Buddha
for one note here so now we have your
instance and you basically can start
creating your database so you can choose
normal DDL SQL DDL or you can use our
editor here in the console to create
your table now for the demo purpose I
use this UI editor I'm adding some
information primary key selecting my age
as a primary key and I create this table
and within like a couple of quicks
I have a database where I can run
queries against and I can also check the
T schema
now I mentioned online updates so I can
for instance add another column and I
forgot the name of a singer I want to
give it a string and
let's say like hundred characters should
be enough I can save this and if I
reload this page you can see here that
we instantly see that this schema update
is in ProQuest now this is done in a
transaction
so you're basically at a specific time
stamp you will have that's the new
schema available and you can accommodate
that in your in your application now if
you've joined the keynote this morning
you you might have seen or are familiar
with this schema so I built a ticket
broker system so to say well I have a
ticket database where I'm selling
tickets all around the world and what's
really important in this case is that I
sell each ticket only once I also wanted
to have a system which is as realistic
as possible so in this database we
basically have an event table which was
all our events that are happening around
the world and we have different seating
categories and venues that these events
are happening in so you can think of
like a VIP seating premium seating
general seating and then once this event
is actually happening I attach also some
prices to these categories so we have a
ticket category table and at the end we
also have for each of these tickets that
are available in our system we have a
ticket in our take a table so for the
demo database that we use today in our
in our keynote demo we have actually
about two billion rows two-point billion
tickets available in the database now
this database runs right now live and in
this query I want to select all the
events that are happening from now till
two more evening tomorrow night so I
want to see like what events are still
happening in Italy and what are the
available seats now when I run this
query it will take a while and I will
give me result of like all the events
that I have and all the year tickets
that are available and as you can see
the seats available is a little lower
than the total seats are available so
this database is actually live running
right now what you can do as well is you
can get
explanation a query plan of the query
that you just executed so what you see
here is for instance a CPU time that was
needed you see the the rows that was
returned for this query and you see that
the rows that were scanned now I'm a bit
familiar with this query because I
designed it and I see like there's a lot
of roles scanned here and I think that's
way too many
and if I go to through my career plan I
can see that I'm doing a table scan on
my event table now you might have seen
it you might have missed that in my
query I actually had a filter based on a
timing and I should be should be able to
do something smarter than a table scan
on my event table for a matter of fact
if we look at the event table on the
left side we are seeing that I have some
some indexes defined in my table so I
talked about extensions SQL ANSI 2011
with extensions so one of the things
that you can do which you can do also
like for many other databases is to give
the compiler the great compiler and
optimizer a hint so in this case I want
to force an index and I have event by
date here as my index and say okay
please use this index right now and as
you can see the query got a lot faster
and if we go into the explanation I now
down to four thousand rows scanned
instead of four hundred thousand rows so
you have the possibility to are to also
use the extension that we provide to
improve your queries and optimize your
queries now if you want to get started
with cloud spinner one of the ways that
you can get started with is our Java
client library and I kind of walk
through a small example here for for our
Java client library in this case I'm
using a demo database and the first
thing that I have to do is basically get
some credentials and authentication
against my database if you run that
locally with our G Cloud SDK setup you
basically live in the context the
authentication context of of your G
cloud CLI so I'm basically just getting
these application default credentials
and the next thing that I'm doing is
setting the instance ID that I need and
the database ID that I want to talk to
now my first example that I want to do
here is I wanted to read only
transaction so I get a transaction
context and I execute a query
now this Cree what it does it basically
selects all the multi events that are
happening today through tomorrow so you
have some parameter placeholders which
I'm binding in in my result in my query
down here in my statement builder now
the last thing as you can see I'm
already executing the query there the
last thing that I want to do is already
going through my result set so I'm going
through iterate basically through my
results that I'm getting and I'm
executing result as fetching the results
so here I can do a get skewing and I can
use either positional arguments or I can
use the column name in my example so I'm
using the positional because I'm lazy
and then I'm executing that and as I can
see everything hopefully if I didn't do
any mistakes I will see some events
coming up down here as you can see so I
have all my multi events that are
happening from today to tomorrow now I
talked about a time bounded queries so
one thing that I can do in my read-only
transactions I can actually add
timestamp bound which sets the maximal
staleness that allow for a query so I
have to edit this here and if I execute
that again or run this again it goes
against the read replica and can
directly serve that data from the read
replica of our basically consulting the
leader of the pack so screw the next
thing that I want to show is the how the
right looks
so if I have a right only transaction I
basically worked with mutations now what
is a mutation a mutation is basically
any changes in my tables and you have to
look at mutations as like on cell level
so interesection we support up to 20
sours and mutations if you have a table
with five columns and you load one row
into this color in this table you have
five mutations if you have to find an
index on the table with another two
columns and you insert one row you
basically have seven mutations now here
in this case I basically add an account
in my table and I run that and if we go
back to my database I go my demo
instance and go to my accounts and go on
preview we see that I have insert here
an account now the next thing if you
want to do a read/write transaction you
basically obtain a transaction runner
that we can see here so basically we we
execute or we run a read white
transaction and to that readwrite
transaction we provide a transaction
callable from a transaction runner so
basically is a function that you give to
that run function and in this run
function you define what you want to do
in terms of reading and updating your
data so in this case I'm selecting my
account I'm updating the name of my
account and then I'm adding these
mutations to my transaction and run this
transaction now why are we doing this is
in a in a transaction runnable the
reason is that our client libraries to
automatic retries of transactions if
they fail so this makes it easier for us
/ to basically do the recovery from
failed transactions and and we run them
again so now if I go to my database and
check the preview again you see that I
updated my name
all right with this I'm going back to
the slides so the last thing that I want
to talk about for from the slides once
we switch is the in terms of like how it
does span or fit into the storage
portfolio that we have on our cloud
platform so I won't just mention a
couple of things here when when do you
use spanner just wanted to reiterate
there are two major use cases for
spanner if you need a high ratable
system which scales horizontally for for
a transactional workload and reads and
writes spanner is your way to go if even
if you have a low amount of data you can
use it also if you have a lot of data
that you want to scale basically your
horizontally again that is a way to go
for spanner we have a lot of other
options under the Google cloud platform
portfolio if you come from a my scale or
Postgres world we have a managed service
called cloud SQL which you can move to
basically as lift and shift if you want
to if you are looking at a more like no
SQL world where like have data that is
document based you're looking at cloud
datastore or if you have key value based
workloads which need like very low
latency is for reads and writes and high
scalability you look at cloud BigTable
if you have things like blob stores like
videos photos things like that or any
kind of files you look into the cloud
storage world and if you wanna do data
analytics over relational data so
basically data warehouse applications or
scenarios you look into bigquery which
is our distributed and very scalable
data warehouse for relational data with
this thank you very much and I hope you
enjoyed the session thank you
you